こんにちははじめ社長です皆様スマホ力電池なくなりませんか外出先とかでスマホの
電池が切れたときみなさんはどうするかと言いますと
5番車バッテリーを使いますコードを入れてかでスマホを充電すると思うんですけども
先ほど5番えばって言ってもやっぱり第44の前でバックに入ってる流行ってるんです
か
やっぱり何事もねやっぱ容量が大きい方がいいじゃ結局も入れバッテリー課題
容量だったら偶然も何回もできるし長い時間充電もできるんですけども
私はどんなジャパンとじゃないと私は文がまっ大容量もっともっとぉ
ほんっとごめんちょっとテンションが上がり過ぎたあっ端保4回くらい2点できるん
ですけども僕みたいなスマホケリーユーザー
常にゲームしたり動画とか見てる僕のような人間には境界の5番に貼って言っておった
ねぇ
もっと大容量
欲しいひとまずモバイルバッテリーをたくさん準備しましたーー
[音楽]
準備しすぎたかはあるなぁ1万 ma が100個あるんでこれで100万目2
アンペアでございますスマホ2で回数量じゃ回までいけます
[音楽]
一人じゃ使えないこんな沢山ので一人じゃ使えん
ヘリコプター飛んでるこんな沢山の場合バッテリーがあって会おう重いわけですこれ丸
ごとかじって持ち歩か日にも行かないし一人で使い切ることはないと思うのでみんなで
配りましょうみんなに全国もみんなその後中電させ北1にいたともう大ような次で使え
ない外に行ってこのちょうだい及ぼばいるバッテリーがあればロック以外の人もみんな
誰もずれ
できるんじゃないかと思いまして古いスマホ充電器屋さんをやろうと思います
外ですも入ってるてばみんな充電が切れると思うのでや大容量って素晴らしい市長は僕
だけじゃなく他のみんなにも化け与えられることができますか
電力も大容量私の心も大容量そして目指すは大統領
果たして人が来るんでしょうかネット網
san
ん
これ含む5でそんな人多いんでかなり大勢の人増えるのではないでしょうかね
道
[音楽]
ana
ちょっと嘘れ厳しさだけしていっ
[音楽]
じゃあ
バッハ
いろんな人に
ん
幸せをあげたいな誰か刑務ろこっからそっとでいたします
[音楽]
これでいつでも充電できますはーい
ane
ん
バナー
goo
を持っていた
あっあーっ
wni
me
始めたじゃあはいえーまぁな感じない方が薄そうなっ
はい
皆さん充電できましたできましたか
有没のこそばいばい気をつけてりゃ嫌な
えっ
[音楽]
ん
ありますか e ウィングに決めちゃったんだよ
お帰ります町向田してるなぁん
を全部均じゃ
hers で出来るじゃないかなんだーっ
意外と評判良くんが結構みんな使ってくれましたことに荒れるなぁ
で今回のこの動画大容量をテーマに動画を作ってみました
ソフトなんでではですね月々5ギガのプランになんと1000円たったので
+だけで月々なんと20ギガも使える超お得な大容量プランに変更することができます
私でお得ですよ
未だなど25歳以下の人だったら毎月1000円の割引のサービスが受けられます僕も
ギリギリ受けられます僕ですねめちゃくちゃ通信整形でかかっちゃう人なんですよ
ちょっとまた別にこのプランはぜひ入っておくべきかなど僕も覚え
ましたね10ギガもあれば多分月々速度制限を気にせずスマホ利用できると思うので
是非皆さん入ってみてください
大容量いしょ
[音楽]
4日